[Music]
sean is in charlotte north carolina hi
sean how are you
hey good afternoon gentlemen hope you're
doing well yeah we are sir how can we
help
hey just a uh trying to get some clarity
um
just some just a back story uh i'm a
single dad
uh 47 years old i have
a 230 000 home i still owe 132
000 on it my salary is about 120 a year
i have currently in my savings
175 000 now
i've done some research and and i just
kind of
stumbled across you and so i've been
trying to follow the baby steps
i still owe 15 on an automobile that i
plan on paying off this week
which will leave me 160 um
and in in reading your your
direction and kind of following up with
that i guess my next step would be to
put
35 into an emergency account pay the
rest on the home but my question is this
i also have a senior who is going to
soon start college and i plan on moving
out of that home in the next four years
and buying another home on more land
so should i take that money and try to
invest it somewhere
should i just pay it toward the home now
let me back up i also have
i have three hundred thousand dollars in
a 401k and a hundred thousand dollars in
company stock
okay so i'm just trying to get some
direction on where this money should be
that's you sean you have done an amazing
job of saving where did the
175 000 come from that you have in
savings
i actually in the over the last two
years i actually cashed out
some non-qualified stock options in
anticipation of my son going to college
okay my mindset originally was to help
him with college
but then the more i discussed it with
folks you know the more
that they they said well that money
could be better used elsewhere
so that's what i'm trying to i'm kind of
trying to maximize where i use that
money how's he gonna go to school
well i mean he's got you know he's got a
little bit of it taken care of but
obviously it's either going to be he's
going to have to take out through their
loans which i
don't want him to have to do i want to
help him whoever's telling you that
that's a plan
listen whoever you're listening to that
says that's a plan as an idiot
okay you don't need to listen that's you
okay
invest the money and your son takes out
student loans
well that's a dumb butt suggestion
okay you wouldn't do that you know you
wouldn't do that you're a saver
you wouldn't have even thought about
that so now you've got good common sense
dude
and i think you trust your instincts uh
and your instincts are telling you
that if you paid off your house and your
car and you had an emergency fund
and you have a hundred thousand dollars
in additional stock that's not tied up
in retirement
that the boys going to school without
any dead gum debt
you don't have a house payment anymore
and that's what i hoped for yeah yeah i
guess i was just
i guess i'm just scared to take that
huge amount of money and and pay it off
toward the house
um if you hate it you can go get you a
mortgage later
yeah right and you're talking about you
may sell it in four years you may
not either way you don't have a payment
but think about it the home is still
going to appreciate
and it's going to sell for what it sells
for you take that and then you buy the
next house yeah if you hate being debt
free you can get your mortgage
so so you so you think my best avenue
here is to keep the 35 and the six buck
emergency fund pay off the car
and the home yes and just continue
investing in my 401k
or should i be trying to stop and stop a
second stop a second
okay just breathe this in for a second
okay you don't have a house payment you
don't have a car payment
you have 35 000 plus a hundred thousand
stock plus your 401 k
you make 120.
does that not feel peaceful to you
oh it's it's it's very peaceful yeah and
there's a reason for that is you you
you need to do personal finance not just
with your mind
but also with your heart because your
heart is where you measure risk and
people who leave
risk out of these scenarios they're
suggesting to you
are the ones that haven't lived life
very long
and i'm old so i've seen risk i've done
some stupid butt stuff in my life i've
seen risk
and you don't want risk and so you're
gonna be a single dad
with a paid for house making 120
what you can't cash flow on college you
can use some of that stock to do
and your son's going to go to school
when you get ready to move to that land
you're going to sell the house and when
you have the closing you know what
they're going to hand you a check
for all of it
you're not losing a dime
sean does anyone else in your family own
their home free and clear
you may have lost him you know it this
is a mindset change
you know dave and you know i i can
imagine too you go from seeing that
dollar amount sitting in the savings
account
right to now all of a sudden talking
about using it but just like you did
given the mindset of not having the car
payment not having the mortgage payment
then what when i stand not lightly but
when i stand on a stage
in front of 5000 people and i say i want
you guys
to imagine what it'd be like to have no
debt no master card
no discovered bondage
no american distress no car payment no
student loan
not even a house payment just breathe
that in when there's a crowd that says
you can
audibly hear the sigh yeah you sure can
and that's called common sense well it's
not sophisticated
yes it is if you actually understand
risk
it's sophisticated it's more
sophisticated than the dumb butt ideas
to invest the money and take out a
student loan
that's just straight up dumb but yeah i
mean that burns me up
somebody telling that young guy to do
that he has done such a good job
follow your instincts sean follow your
instincts they're telling you what to do
and follow through on it you don't have
to do it because we said do it
it's not like you're on the dave ramsey
playing this is your grandmother's plan
yeah your grandmother would have done
this well
most of your grandmothers um if not
maybe your grandfather but i mean you
know still
the point is it used to be called common
sense it's just not common anymore
everybody tries to find some shortcut by
going around the barn six times and do
some kind of double back flip
sophisticated
bullcrap microwave it nuke it make it
happen quick no shortcut to
any place it's worth no no it didn't
this is a crockpot baby